Canada's Cirque de Soleil which started
as a small group of street performers is
now a unique player in the global
entertainment industry based in Montreal
Cirque is the largest theatrical
producer in the world their shows have
played in 450 cities in more than 50
countries and to almost 200 million
spectators on Wednesday of this week
they announced they'll open to a new
audience with their first ever residency
in China Adriana Diaz got a rare look
inside the cirque du soleil 'he's
creative heart how does the company that
introduced the world to a new kind of
circus continue to push the imagination
fantasy to life they do the unexpected
that's blasphemous in the world of magic
they open their doors and show their
secrets for one day a year as part of
Canada's day of culture or Geoghan a
dilemma to cirque de soleil invites the
public to their massive montreal
headquarters they give a close-up look
at how their shows are built from
scratch from homemade props to makeup
try to finish with the head keep you can
to movement
we're actual performers are practicing
in front of the public to see it's very
polite people want to keep it not too
loud in here so that she can focus do
you want to be like this woman one day
what do you think the ringmaster of this
creative powerhouse is president and CEO
danielle de mer
is it hard to pull back the curtain it's
it's a privilege to have to come
backstage but at the same time I like
our our Quebecers to discover and to be
part of it but this entertainment Empire
has humble beginnings Canadian street
performers including former CEO key
laliberté created Cirque in 1984 today
they're a billion dollar company their
headquarters is a kaleidoscope of
costumes characters and clowning around
at the open house getting hands-on is
highly encouraged and for some highly
difficult
Jeremie dude can you help me okay yeah
but others fit right in you surprised
when you came here by what you saw yes
eggs but unless you expected less yes
and what do you think now that you're
here and they're not just going behind
the scenes they're going above them so
what we are standing on right now it's
hard to stay standing because it's so
wobbly it's a little scary but this is
what they call a technical grid this is
where they hang all the equipment lights
ropes for the acrobats and that sort of
thing and each square inch of this grid
has to be able to hold 300 pounds
okay here what do you want folks to take
away from coming here to your
headquarters I want them to understand
how much work there is behind it
I want them to understand that we're not
in industry where art is on we were
getting a lot of phone calls a lot of
people who want to visit Cirque du
Soleil is head of social action an EQ to
overseas this bring your audience to
work day it is really an opportunity for
us to open our doors a bit like a willy
wonka moment so that you open the doors
of the factory and you finally figure
out what's behind those doors and you
can see the magic where it all comes
together and creates those beautiful
shows no golden ticket is required and
free entry comes with a tour costume
production manager David nappin showed
us around each elaborate creation starts
out as white fabric that's then died and
dramatized in house a costume is part of
the performance it brings emotion it's
like at Cirque we say we like to invoke
provoke and evoke and I think like the
way we look at our costume and think of
her costume is to bring out that effect
get into care exactly they become the
cricket they become the cricket they
become the the blue nosh they becomes
something that's not them and that's
that's part of a story bigger than we
dance
in the new show I'm gonna be a
hummingbird so that I'll be different
American Luke Anderson says costumes
help him transition from Acrobat to
artist you feel like a different person
I mean you turn into the character for
that that short moment on stage I'm a
hummingbird how do you feel about the
public being able to come in and see
what you guys do I think it's wonderful
when they see us on stage you know they
only see the final product but when they
come and look at the training you can
see how much hard work and time and
effort is put into every small detail
and at the headquarters they could see
how it's all put together fans were
allowed all over the building
except one place this store here is
actually locked because what's happening
behind these closed doors is the
preparations for the China show and that
is off-limits to everyone their
residency in Hangzhou opens next year
it's their big for a - a new frontier
it's one of our top priority right now
because you have 1.5 billion potential
customers we're doing the same thing in
China today that we were doing 34 years
ago at the corner of the street in
Montreal it's convincing people that
we're offering an artistic content that
is totally different if you want to
disrupt the world you have to be
innovative you have to be gutsy you have
to push the boundaries of your
creativity all the time and the people
that are struggling in the business
world right now are the people that are
too traditional
see advice is loosen up exactly and
listen to the young people because when
Gilbert I founded Cirque du Soleil he
was 25 years old so listen to the 25
years old people or the 20 years old
people that have crazy idea and that are
renegade because they're the one that
are going to
in the world for CBS this morning
Saturday Adriana Diaz Montreal Canada
I remember when Cirque du Soleil came to
the United States 1993 or so and it was
just the epic thing to hit us and Wow
spectacular shows spectacular costumes